the Spongebob movie sponge out of water
is the second spongebob film adapted
from a billion seasons because it's
actually been going since 1999 that's 16
years ago in this movie plankton is once
again trying to steal the krabby patty
formula from spongebob and mr. Krabs but
this is different because this time they
actually work together they build a time
machine they eventually are transported
out of water and Antonio Banderas is a
pirate reading a story who somehow
interacts with said story hey spongebob
- that's all I know
now I'll be completely honest the first
three seasons of Spongebob I was
actually a really big fan of to me back
in the day they were actually like some
of Nickelodeon's more edgy entertainment
like Ren and Stimpy or Rocko's Modern
Life
Rocko's Modern Life I'm a big fan of
classic 90s Nicktoons and those first
few seasons of Spongebob felt like that
then the producers of those seasons left
and the show became extremely popular
and it became increasingly more
sanitized as it went along the good news
is the producers from those first three
seasons came back to work on this movie
and that's why I didn't mind this movie
I actually had some fun with Sponge Bob
- they were a moment - this movie that
actually did feel adult there were
moments of this movie that reminded me
of the first few seasons of Spongebob
you know that really hard edge painted
animation cells where there's like
people are sweating and all disgusting
and dirty and nasty like in Ren Stimpy
all those intense close-ups you know
what made the first few seasons of
Spongebob so hilarious and I've heard a
lot of people say this and in some ways
it is very true there are moments of
this movie that feel like an acid trip
it feels like a STONER movie at times
and that's definitely something to say
because the majority of my screening
audience that I saw this movie with were
children that more than likely weren't
even alive in 1999 when the show
initially started so if you were like me
and you thought the first three seasons
of Spongebob were the best and you might
actually find some enjoyment in this
movie if you were more concerned that it
was going to be a little more sanitized
like that first spongebob movie that
came out ten years ago
time flies my friends it's a little
frightening but like I said if you were
more concerned about it being more
family friendly and a little more
childish than you would expect there
actually are some adult jokes in this
movie my problems with this movie is
that I do not give a crap about the
Antonio Banderas storyline it does come
into play at some point but it just
seems like this extra thing the movie
keeps going to that I don't care about
and I would just like it to stay
underwater I really liked how there was
a lot of animation in the movie before
the CGI stuff because yeah there is a
CGI sequence and from the posters and
the trailers it might lead you to
believe the entire movies like that but
it's really just the third act that was
CGI and then it goes right back to
traditional animation fairly quickly
there's a lot more traditional than you
would have expected which was very
refreshing to me because when I saw the
previews I was like oh great they're
just doing more CGI because apparently
everything has to be CGI nowadays
because no kid wants to watch
traditional animation anymore but
gratefully there's a lot of that in this
movie and that was awesome to see but
there isn't quite enough of that
edginess I wanted just a little bit more
of the edgy humor that made spongebob
awesome for the first few seasons still
I think kids are going to have fun with
this movie I think some grownups can sit
and watch it and not hate themselves and
overall I would say it's not really that
bad of a time to spend in the theater
unless you hate Sponge Bob if you hate
Sponge Bob just stay away you're going
to loathe this experience but it
actually is not as bad as you may expect
I'm gonna give Sponge Bob
sponge out of water a B - guys thank you
so much for watching I also want to let
you know that my second appearance on
screen junkies one of my favorite
YouTube channels just went up it is best
90's action movies you can watch myself
Mark Ellis of schmoes know and Nic Mundy
himself Duke it out in a good-natured
battle centered around the very best
90's action movies and I think the very
first bracket will shock you as it
shocked me but those guys are truly
awesome some of the coolest people and
funniest people I met when I was in LA I
left a link for that video in the
description go check it out guys and
thank you so much as always for watching
I'm very grateful and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes